So what went wrong in this application? It
was this right here, the 3G data connection.
What ended up happening is this application is
currently violating data and battery constrains of mobile.
>> So what the application should have done is by default download
the video at 480p or the lowest resolution, because the user's on 3G.
>> Yeah, and what ends up happening is if you're trying
to download this humongous video over this really slow network connection,
it'll take forever to download the video,
which will drain your cellular, because it's
cellular radio. It's going to drain your battery.
Two, it will take forever to download
the video, so the playback is going to be really janky anyway. And so just
avoid it. Just downgrade to a lower resolution or queue it for playback later.